think about it think about it all the
round though what hey didn't see you
there welcome to first game 92nd
portraits okay so I'm supposed to draw
like one of those streets our street
artists [ __ ] throw the [ __ ] in
there this is pretty awesome oh god I
spent way too much time on all the wrong
things [ __ ] [ __ ] damn it okay next
customer an alien
alright that makes sense it's impossible
to draw this man without it looking like
a damn it great now it looks like a
hentai Sun up but I say clay magnifique
my mad madam or Monsieur I don't [ __ ]
know I forget those fabulous lips
beautiful I'm pretty proud of now look
at that swag f [ __ ] you I'm even doing
shading and [ __ ] now this is some Lex
next-level drawing it's a very
satisfying game I gotta say looks so
good what do I get
hey hey I'll take a beat I never failed
a customer before and I'm not planning
to starting today well god damn it
alright I tried it Oh B hey I make money
that's the myth 5 total earnings day 1
alright that one could have been better
that was pretty good I was amazing
10 out of 10 let's do another day hey my
friend II love this game I probably
shouldn't spend so much [ __ ] time on
the goddamn background dammit
ah yes yes look bail money thanks best
painting
I really should become an artist I feel
like I have what the actual [ __ ] is that
nope I can do this guy a true artist
always captures the man behind the face
which is synonym for we need Photoshop
but it
it's not invented yet a little bit of
pubic hair there on top that's very nice
a little bit of pubic hair there that's
nice
think I made too many teeth all right
we're gonna have to save some time there
we go it's art you're welcome what oh
hello
alright alright a Miss I realize I never
drew a penis yet so there you go hey I
got one dollar I feel like I really
could
you know if YouTube fails I could always
just turn to drawing on the streets
Sam pie in the sheets sake ah
Yolo you made it back to my humble
everything I am everything like it to
you it's my most offensive French accent
I can pull up where is my biggest
influence
je m'appelle don't forget I'm kidding I
studied French for life that's why I'm
so good at this fringe
[Music]
dumb ways to die too
let's play it oh we ain't drowned town
okay
Oh swipe stay between the flanks
all right like his haircut easy no
problem
he got sad like they didn't die dad yet
avoid this I did it oh yeah not today
piranhas oh yeah oh right the don't know
bad
Oh God find the treasure okay I can't
one walk up into the club all right we
got a thousand oh god lace up beautiful
okay Ben it's okay
what connect avoid like them so fast
spin all right suit some Team Rocket
piggyback don't lick the pole just don't
I can't
aah oh my forehead oh that is that is
not good all right we fighting the
penguin
[ __ ] you you
sweet complete the jump oh [ __ ]
it's a giant jet is gonna come out of
you
why do I am I wearing a condom why not
hey Brad Oh God welcome brah I solemnly
swear not to do dumb [ __ ] around trains
I promise that's it what is it
wheel of misfortune what what spin2win
are you sure are you alright
[Music]
what you can't just much this it's
horrible horrible all right
[Music]
this game is a game that I've been
wanting to play for a while it's a space
exploration game we're supposed to be on
Mars
I find moonwalking very hard just gonna
walk down the stairs like it's nobody's
business what if we jump will that make
it faster I didn't know that we're so
slow on Mars am I missing something okay
I got in my car yes
let's explore now this is what I call
drifting baby drifting on Mars this is
actually awesome Mayday we're still
driving yes video games
[Music]
I love video games this game is
beautiful Oh Shh this game is gorgeous I
just happened to run into a bug let's
follow this road see where it goes best
racing simulator I have ever raced in my
entire life look at this [ __ ] Isaac
Newton was like hey gravity and this
game was like you know what [ __ ] off
No what am i cargo hey you watch hang
with the controller maybe that will make
it work better I don't [ __ ] know what
is that another house
nothing's gonna stop this mission I'm
not giving up I don't care if my car is
upside down I will not let anyone down
except this car I said when I was first
accepted to space Academy they left this
is my chance to prove myself out [ __ ]
captain Johnson if he was here he'd be
smiling at me saying you drive like my
mom still Jesus Christ this is this is
[ __ ] impressive all right I better
make it back at home inside it's another
it's another parallel universe would you
mind if I borrow your car Larry I like
how it looks like oh yes can't see
anything
don't know what's going on but I know
for one thing's [ __ ] certain it's
that it was not a good idea to drive a
car on the goddamn Mars alright you know
I'm too [ __ ] confused for this hey I
actually you know what it might have
been buggy as hell but it was an
enjoyable experience and I think all of
these games are really cool so check
them out in the description and have
some fun leave it like if you enjoyed
watching this video bros I really
appreciate it as always stay awesome
[Music]